joining me now dr. Anthony Falchi
director of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases and a
member of the white house coronavirus
task force so let's just start in
January or February when was the first
time that you realized that this was a
major problem because I remember in late
January you were telling people early
February this was nothing to be
concerned for most Americans Americans
for the most part were not at risk it
was in January at a time when the
Chinese were saying first that it was
only going from an animal to a human and
then when there were human cases that
look like they were transmitted that it
was very inefficiently transmitted it
was at that time in I believe
mid-january that we made the statement
that if in fact that's true that this is
mostly animal to human and we're not in
China and it's very inefficiently spread
that in fact it may not be something
that is of a major threat outside of
China when it became clear that not only
is it transmitted efficiently from human
to human but that it was very very
contagious in the sense of easily
transmittable and it also had a higher
degree of morbidity and mortality at
that point it became very clear that we
were in for a problem because we were
getting travel cases from China and even
though we cut off the Chinese pretty
quickly once it's seated in this country
then it does what any highly
transmissible virus does right so
there's nothing inconsistent with the
information we had no I totally
understand you were working with the
information that was available at the
time at this point do you feel like you
were misled by the Chinese do you feel
misled by the World Health Organization
because you had I said said nice things
about the leader of the World Health
Organization now looking back it looks
like he was not completely honest or
maybe he was deceived
how do you feel about that you know I
don't know where the missteps went the
only thing I know what the end result
was that early on we did not get correct
information and the incorrect
information was propagated right from
the beginning because you know when the
first cases came out that were
identified I think on December 31st in
China and we became aware of this they
said this was just animal-to-human
period now we know retrospectively that
there was ongoing transmission from
human to human in China probably at
least a few weeks before then and then
when we finally did get the virus here
it was became clearer than when we
started looking at what's going on that
that was misinformation right from the
beginning so who's ever fault that was
you know we're gonna go back and take a
look at that when this is all over but
clearly it was not the right information
that was given to us right so now that
we've done this almost full-scale
national economic lockdown are there
things that cross your mind and think
maybe would you have done it any
differently could you have done
everybody under 45 go to work could you
have maybe done regional shutdowns could
you have maybe just concentrated in the
hot spots could you have had everybody
wear masks to work are there other other
things that you think maybe you could
have done to spare the country from a
full economic shutdown well my advice
was that we were dealing with a
situation with the transmissibility was
efficient enough that we could not take
the chance that we would just let people
get infected and think that there would
be no really very serious consequences
because people who were young even
though they did not necessarily get ill
at all clearly would be the vectors to
transmit it to the people who are highly
vulnerable the elderly and those with
underlying conditions so one of those
things that you can look at is how do
you cut that off and the way the best
way to do it is to have a physical
separation the way we have with the
guidelines that are now in effect I have
a very high regard for you doctor foul
Chi but I just want to be fair because
there are some people who were very
angry with you who think that this it I
guess advice to the President to shut
everything down to close businesses has
really cost a lot of people's jobs their
the livelihood their businesses
everything what would you say to those
people well I mean obviously that's very
unfortunate I mean that's a consequence
that's they know you have to balance the
attempt to save as many lives as you can
what is known as a deleterious effect on
the economy which is the reason why
right now we're looking very carefully
about how we can possibly in a safe way
reopen as they say reopen the country to
the economic opportunities that we have
we felt at the time and still do now
that that was the right thing to do
could they have been other approaches I
mean I'm humble enough to know that
maybe there could be that was the choice
we made based on the information that we
have one can always second-guess but
that happens this is a serious situation
that has impacted a lot of people right
and you believe we're at our peak
probably this weekend fingers crossed
hopefully I hope so I mean what we're
seeing for example in a place like New
York which we predicted correctly that
this would be a really bad week where
every day the next day would be more
deaths than the previous day but as that
was happening the engine that fuels the
outbreak in New York namely the number
of new cases that lead to
hospitalizations that lead to intensive
care that lead to death clearly are
significantly less this week than they
were the previous week so it seems
almost a paradox but it really isn't at
the same time that the deaths continue
to go up we're having indications that
we are reaching that peak that apex and
will start to come down if it acts the
way we've seen it act in China that
decline will be
very steep so we may go from a
significant number of deaths even more
than we've seen to a situation where
there's a radical drop in the number of
deaths which will be the last to see but
the hospitalizations are already
indicating that we're going in the right
direction all right we can only hope
doctor foul Chi thank you so much you're
quite welcome good to be with you